>>> ISN SPECIALIVE
CO OF THE RUSSIAINVASION
WSAI.O HAVE IORTAAK
KIRSAN TT UKRAINIA
HAVE PUSHED BA A RUSSIANON ACRO
THASN WALSH AND TEAMERTHEIR OW .
SIEGE RIGHT NOW. GETTING W THEEE
OVING CENTER.
NEW THEY
ISHED AN AIRDG
HIS
THIS MORNING WUNDERSTA
HE OBOLON
DISTRICT IN THRTHERN
OUTSKIRTS OF THEY.N SEE THE CITE
GETTING EVER C
LEADER OF THE IAK YOU SO MUC
US.
ELUSOBSERVING THIS
>> HI.
I WILLEMAIN .
WEHEG THE NEWS
REGARDING WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
F EE
SETS
TIS WHEN THE SIRENO GO DHE
SHELTER AND HIDE THERE WIT
THEREBEEN  COUPLE OF AIRSTRIKEE
MY HWEVER, WE HAVEN'T
SE PEOPLE KILLED
SO WE'VE PREPA BEAR ARMS D YEDA
RIFL RIF
KYIV.KNOWCAN ARRIGHT NO NOT, BU
HT
LITT B
BECAUSE FOR THREE HS
NEED PROTECTION  AND WR GOT IT
FROM ANY OF THE TR ORT.W WE SEER
RE IA LOREIS NOT RLLY
G THE MORALE OF THE PEOPLEIKES
THE TIME.>>Y SAFE NEED TO TAKE
PLEASE DO IF THERE ARE T
EXPLODING BEHIND YOU ANDHE
WINDOWS ARE  DND THAT.
WHILE  HAVE YOU, IN E TH IN
IM THE ERE YOE IN THE CIT
NG DO YOU THINK
YOU AND THE CITY CAN RESIST?
I UNDERSTAND T EVENTS ARE  CLOS
Y CREW
A COUPLEF SET OF PEOPLE WITH
TERRIA
FIGHT FOR
NOT TO LETSIANS THERE IS LOTS OF
COMING IN D OUARVERY WHAT WE HE
EL FIGHT, TELL
>>, WE UNDERD SOME00 SMALLRM B
HANDED OUT IN JUST LASW E YON JN
IN THE DEFENSE IF IT DOES
COME.
UNODED ORLDO EH?ENRE
ROUND
IS THE ENOUGH  LP YOU?
>> WE VEFUL
GETTING, HEVU WILL E NCWILL NOT
NEED NOT ONLY SANCTIONS, WE NEE.
TO FLNE OG WE HAVE BEENORE
.EN ASKIN
COUNTRIES.
WEAVR
PARTNERS SAYING WE KW YOU
CANNOT FIGHT YOU CAN
GIVE ARMY AT
COVERAGE
S THE MOST IMPOR THING
RIW.
RAREE WILL DVES.
WE HE  KILLINGS ONOUR SOILS FORG
YEARS WHEN THEY WERE TRYING GETN
SOMETHING YOU CAN REALLY